hormone therapy puberty blockers and a
sex change operation all without you
knowing or consenting here he is just
absolutely murdering new let me just say
something about parents rights because
he says California respects parents
rights this is Rich he's been telling a
lot of Whoppers tonight this may be the
biggest in California if you're a parent
in Iowa or New Hampshire South Carolina
your minor child can go to California
without your knowledge or without your
consent and get hormon pH therapy
puberty blockers and a sex change
operation all without you knowing or
consenting how in the heck is that
honoring parents' rights when you're
bringing people from out of state to go
around their parents' backs and getting
life-altering surgeries that is radical
that is Extreme that is an assault on
parents rights you know what it's not
for you to decide it's for the parents
to decide and the parents do not want
their kids going to these other man he
is so evil it's like my jaw is dropping
as I'm watching it even though I've seen
it 10 times Nome these kids just want to
survive think how psychotic that is so
an 8-year-old in Florida says that he is
a girl that means that by California law
he is allowed to go to California
against his parents' wishes and get all
of these drugs and new some and chop up
their gals and everything else and Nome
thinks he's the good guy because they
just want to survive he wants to own
your children like it is as simple as
that he wants to basically show your
kids corn and chop their genitals off
generally that would be thought of as
someone that's a bit
weird not when it comes to
California